En este video vamos a hablar de la idea de
fracción y veremos que hay muchas formas de
pensar en una fracción, pero primero pensemos
en lo fundamental. Digamos que tengo este
cuadrado y podemos considerar esto como un
entero, así que permíteme escribir esto:
esto es 1 entero. Ahora, lo que voy a hacer
es dividir este entero en 4 partes iguales,
así: lo divido en 2 partes iguales y luego con
otros dos cortes lo divido en 4 partes iguales,
entonces hay 4 partes iguales. Y ahora lo que voy
a hacer es seleccionar una de esas partes iguales,
selecciono esta parte. Ahora la pregunta es ¿qué
fracción del entero representa la parte que he
sombreado en rojo? Bueno, es 1 de las 4 partes
iguales, ¿verdad? He sombreado una de 1, 2, 3,
4 partes iguales, entonces escribimos esto como
esta fracción, esta sección representa 1/4 del
entero. Hay dos formas de pensar en esto, puedes
verlo como 1 de las 4 partes iguales o puedes
verlo como 1 entero dividido entre 4 y obtienes
exactamente esto. Ahora hagamos otro ejercicio,
y esta vez pensemos en cómo podríamos representar
1 entre 8. Bueno, podemos dividir este entero,
en este caso es un rectángulo, lo dividimos en 8
partes iguales, así que hagámoslo: aquí lo divido
en 2 partes iguales, y ahora puedo dividir cada
una de ellas en 2 partes iguales para obtener 4
partes iguales, y luego divido de nuevo en 2 cada
una de ellas para tener 8 partes iguales. Como
estoy dibujando esto a mano, las divisiones no
son exactas, pero espero que esto te dé una idea.
Entonces ahora tengo 8 partes iguales, y ahora
voy a seleccionar sólo una de estas partes, y
esto representa 1/8. Y puedo elegir cualquiera de
éstas, pero elijo esta para mostrar que no tiene
que ser necesariamente la primera parte. De nuevo,
este cuadrado de aquí que estoy sombreando en rojo
representa 1/8 del entero. Ahora veamos algunos
ejemplos más que he sombreado con antelación,
y lo que quiero que hagas ahora es pausar el video
y que en un pedazo de papel o mentalmente trates
de responder si consideras esta figura púrpura
como un entero: ¿qué fracción representa esta
parte roja? Si consideras esta forma azul como el
entero, ¿qué fracción representa esta parte roja?
Si ves este triángulo amarillo, ¿qué fracción
representa esta parte roja? Entonces te invito
a que pauses el video ahora. Bueno, veamos cada
uno de estos. En este rectángulo tenemos 3 partes
iguales y hemos sombreado 1 de ellas, así que este
rectángulo rojo de aquí representa 1/3 del entero.
Ahora, aquí en este círculo que parece un pastel,
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 partes iguales, y hemos
sombreado una de estas 5 partes iguales, entonces
esta pequeña porción del pastel representa 1/5,
esto de aquí es 1/5 de todo el pastel. Este es
interesante. Puede que te sientas tentado a decir
"Bueno, tengo 4 partes y he sombreado una, así que
esto debe representar 1/4", pero recuerda que es
necesario que las partes sean iguales, y viendo
esta parte de aquí nos damos cuenta de que no
tiene el mismo tamaño que esta parte de aquí o de
esta parte de aquí; éstas no son 4 partes iguales,
así que no podemos decir que esto es una cuarta
parte del triángulo, no podemos afirmar eso.